all Cody ever talked about was how much
he was sad that he was losing this house
that Christine had he loved it he didn't
want to lose it so it sort of felt like
he was using me and my buying power to
save this house that he loves Janelle
Brown accuses her husband Cody of using
her for money on Sister Wives Cody and I
have definitely had challenges this year
because we've had to spend more time
apart than we have ever probably so
that's definitely been something I've
had to kind of really think about and
the challenges keep on coming following
Christine's big move to Utah after her
split from Cody the sale on her house
falls through and Cody wanting to keep
the house and the family suggests
Janelle buy it before they build her new
home on their coyote Pass Property and
Janelle well she's not happy about it I
can't afford
both house mortgages I can't buy this
house and in any shape or form Finance
another house no matter even if it's
small like I I just can't never did Cody
say hey honey let's do this it's a house
for you
all Cody ever talked about was how much
he was sad that he was losing this house
that Christine had like I would be in
this home that isn't really one of my
favorite homes and it would be where I
would be
forever stuck and as Cody keeps pressing
the matter Janelle who'd rather begin
building her own home than by
Christine's gets more angry I want my
own house we've been in Flagstaff for
four freaking years and I don't have a
house still I've been pushing this house
of Christine's on to Janelle for a long
time and Janelle's like stop it she
doesn't want to buy Christine's house
she wants to build her own house he's
not listening at all to the reasons that
I can't do this or don't want to do this
it's almost like he just feels like if
he keeps telling me and he's gonna
steamroll me and I'm gonna lay down and
be like okay we'll do it I'm trying to
be a husband a father to their children
and a lover to two people who may not
see eye to eye that's a real Challenge
and later in the episode Cody opens up
about his strained relationship with
Janelle men don't feel love from women
who don't respect them I feel like
Janelle struggles to respect me or show
me respect
might be an unfair statement I don't
know maybe it's just the way that we
argue
if you don't respect me don't bother
with the love
it just doesn't work in my world
but the arguing doesn't stop there
things continue to get heated between
the two in next week's episode when Cody
gets honest about how he truly feels
about their marriage you and I have been
acting like we weren't a married couple
for most of our marriage you know okay
I'm spitting mad now maybe this is not a
good fit maybe this doesn't work it
feels like we're unraveling I'm thinking
what the hell am I doing here as I
unravel it it seems that who I am
unraveling this with
each wife sometimes more one wife than
others I'm not naming names
this unravels to the point where I'm
like I I am getting kind of in dark
place going why are you even why'd you
even want to live this way why are you
still living this way if it sucks I
don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around
[Music]